okay welcome back this is usually the
time when we go to the mailbag and uh we
you know solicit questions from the
audience but we have something real
special today we have um on the line
with us precious metals expert philip
patrick and uh first of all philip
thanks for joining us
thank you very much for having me
now
uh i want to start kind of broad strokes
here because i i i've kind of confessed
to you i'm a culture guy i'm a kind of
focus on social issues and that sort of
thing
i'm not an economics guy
so
i i might ask some questions and we have
my producer sean here and he's he's his
role is to ask the smarter questions
so i might have some dumb questions and
hopefully you're okay with that so let's
just start like basically with the
economy
are you optimistic
about the economy generally are we are
we on the road to recovery or do you
have a uh
kind of doom and gloom outlook for the
future
sadly at least sort of short to medium
term i don't think there's too much good
news on the horizon um
we have 40 year high inflation i think
as everybody knows today markets are
reeling and the federal reserve are in a
very tough position right now in order
to get inflation under control they're
going to have to stimulate a recession
they're going to have to raise interest
rates to try and kill demand and that
does not spell good times for stocks
or housing markets like i said short to
medium term so i think we've got to
weather some tough times in order to get
a handle on these problems so for the
foreseeable future i think we've got a
storm to weather
how do and and how do you explain our
our current economic state just like in
layman's terms it's explained to a
five-year-old like myself
why why why is why are we suffering
right now exactly how do you what do you
trace it back to
look i trace it back to kicking the cam
down the road and we've been doing it
for quite a long time here in the us
really since the crash in 08. um
what we've been doing is stimulating the
markets by keeping interest rates low i
mean the interest rate environment for
the last 12 13 years has been very
abnormal and it's been designed to
stimulate we've printed in that time
period more money than ever before in us
history combined and we've used that
money to stimulate the markets and it
was fantastic for a long time because it
drove stocks up to all-time highs
housing up to all-time highs we all
enjoyed it the problem is money doesn't
work like that by pumping money through
an economy it eventually leads to
inflation right and that's where we are
today so we have these bubbles in the
market fueled by fiscal policy we have
40-year high inflation and now we need
to get a handle on it and essentially
let the air out of that bubble so that's
why we have recession on the horizon and
like i said it came from kicking the can
further down the road what politicians
should have done once the economy
recovered after 08 they should have
raised interest rates contracted the
economy and slowed growth but i think
they were greedy right there was a lot
of political capital hey we turned the
economy around and they kept fueling the
bubble and now we're dealing with it and
philip with inflation
you know everyone of course is feeling
inflation right now so we all have a
somewhat of a handle on it can you can
you kind of just give us the for the
average person who might have heard that
word can you kind of give us a working
definition of inflation something we can
look at and point to and say yes that's
inflation
of course so look inflation means the
things we spend our money on are
becoming more and more expensive the
technical definition is the rising cost
of commodities and services over time
anybody who goes to the grocery store
sees the price of beef eggs milk the
basics increasing on a daily basis in
this climate that is inflation in its
purest form
so is there
how does the the value of our money play
into inflation because you know if the
price of everything is going up
naturally of course the value of the
current money we have is going down is
that right yeah the the buying power is
reducing right dollars are strengthening
in this climate they're not weakening so
dollar devaluation is a little bit
separate to inflation we're seeing
inflation here from a number of
different areas domestic policy here in
the united states i mentioned before
money printing on a huge scale being
continued by the biden administration i
mean the the deficit is 700 billion
dollars this year so printing money
flooding the economy with money fuels
inflation then we have the political
side of things right the war in russia
and ukraine fueling rising
energy costs across europe and of course
food costs across the globe so these
factors are contributing and fueling the
domestic inflation we're seeing here in
the united states and of course this is
a global issue now as well what about uh
since we're defining terms you know the
other one that's become controversial is
is recession itself
uh and so we're we there's there's
warring factions saying whether we're in
a recession or not or what it even means
it seems like in washington they've kind
of i guess it's kind of convenient they
can just redefine the term whatever they
want uh depending on what they need so
so
are we in one and can you give us a
definitive definition of
what what it actually means
of course yeah
look it's very clear what a recession
means the definition has been in place
for decades two consecutive quarters of
negative gdp growth which is exactly
what we've seen for the last two
quarters the biden administration
obviously recession doesn't suit their
political goals so they're attempting to
change the definition it is two quarters
of negative gdp growth that's what it is
we are in a technical recession there's
no other way to look at it
so we can't rely
on
washington dc to
save us here
so what what do you think from uh from
from just a you know in everyday
american
household
uh they have no direct control over
monetary policy so what can they do
to protect themselves in this uh
environment
well you're right look you know the the
big picture is very hard to control
right
as you mentioned our control is very
limited we can go out and vote and push
for change so the trajectory longer term
can move and i think that's important
because with the biden administration's
appetite to spend it's going to be very
difficult to get these problems under
control they're making the federal
reserve's job very difficult
but
that's longer term change i think what
we all need to do is sort of narrow the
scope look at those around us and say
how can we protect
and i think precious metals what we deal
with here at birch very conducive for
climates like this it's a very tough
climate for investors people who are
looking at retirement because the
options are limited stocks historically
have been a very good hedge on inflation
today they're not right stock market's
down about 20 percent for the year so
far so stocks are adding to the problem
of inflation because your money is
coming down at the same time as
everything is becoming more expensive
cash bonds
not working today interest rates are so
low inflation is higher than the rate of
interest on most bonds so people are
losing buying power sitting in bonds or
cash
that's where precious metals come in
they're safe haven assets but more
importantly they're very conducive for
climates like this specifically when
stock markets crash safe haven demand
goes up gold and silver tend to go up
they doubled in value within 18 months
of the last crash on top of that
inflation drives them up remember the
definition i gave before inflation is
the rising cost of commodities and
services over time gold and silver are
commodities so by definition they
increase as the cost of living does so i
think everybody needs to be thinking
about a hedge how can i protect a
portion of my portfolio against the
current economic issues and like i said
precious metals about the best way to do
that in climates like this now how do
you compare
something like gold or silver to to
something like bitcoin we're hearing
that that's a
digital gold we're hearing that's
another hedge against inflation last
time i saw the price though it was it
was a falling so for people who are
hearing that what would you say to them
look gold is ingrained it's been used
for centuries it's used by central
governments today to support currency
it's got a long track record we haven't
seen that with cryptocurrency in fact
you know for a long time cryptocurrency
was moving in lockstep with the nasdaq
so it wasn't providing a hedge as you
rightly point out as inflation has been
skyrocketing here in the united states
crypto has been coming down so it
doesn't have the established
relationship with other markets that we
see with gold so i'm not sure it's a
hedge what it is is a speculative asset
it grew very well for investors now it's
going the other way
are cryptocurrencies are fad
i would say not i think currency broadly
longer term it's a natural progression
for currency to move digital
but there's a lot of question marks will
government move in to that space i think
at some point it makes sense that they
will if that happens what happens to all
of these third-party currencies right
does the government step in and say hey
we're going to start taxing these things
so there's a lot of question marks there
i personally see it as a speculative
asset and gold i see on the opposite end
of the spectrum right you're not going
to put money in gold and quadruple it in
a year we've seen that with crypto but
at the same time it doesn't tend to drop
in the same way either so opposite ends
of the spectrum in many ways
uh phil we know you have a heart out but
i guess my my my last question is uh
well second to last is
well how do you explain so why why is uh
why are precious metals so stable in the
long term how do you explain the
stability of it what makes them so safe
it's just how they've been used if you
look at gold specifically gold is a
store of value and buying power and it
has always been that as an example if
you went back to biblical times one
ounce of gold would buy somebody 400
loafs of bread
today at four dollars and some change
one ounce of gold buys 400 loaves of
bread
so gold's buying power has always
remained consistent which is why
countries use it to support currency
it's actually currency that fluctuates
right as dollars become weaker over time
it takes more weaker dollars to buy that
ounce of gold hence that inverse
relationship between the two gold has
always been a store of wealth it's
finite right it's divisible
that's why it's used as currency so it's
just always been that way and it and you
know for the foreseeable future it
always will
well last question and uh i have to ask
you this because this is just a rule for
everyone that comes in the studio even
even even digitally uh i need to know
do you believe in space aliens are there
aliens in the world
listen
i have to say there are so many planets
there are so many i mean it has to be
somewhere there has to be life on a
planet somewhere
my my knowledge here is very limited but
that's my very basic basic view that was
the correct answer i'm so thankful for
that well phil thank you so much for
joining us on the show if you want to
learn more about precious metals and uh
investing in a stable asset like that
text walsh to 989898
for a free info kit on diversifying into
gold that's walsh to
98989 philip thanks again we appreciate
it
thank you so much for having me
if you want to join my exclusive fan
base or a cult as really is that's what
it is we're joined we're forming a cult
then all you gotta do is click the
subscribe button and ring the bell below
this video to stay up to date with all
my content and if you want even more you
can watch or listen to my show at the
dailywire.com spotify or apple podcast
looking forward to welcoming you to the
sweet baby gang